hey guys it is the 11th of June my name
is Jess McDonald you're watching
gamespot news and the hottest thing in
gaming today is the oculus rift so I'll
give you all the info on that no headset
required if you didn't manage to catch
the oculus rift press conference from
this morning here's a rundown on
everything that mattered the final
consumer model of the headset was
revealed and it was announced that it
will compact were the wireless Xbox one
controller to hook up to your PC
although that wasn't the only controller
revealed oculus will also be offering
their own funny-looking alternative
called oculus touch the two so-called
Halfmoon controllers are set to enable
the tracking of finger poses which
recognize common gestures apparently
flipping the bird in virtual reality
just got a whole lot easier each
controller has a traditional analog
stick two buttons and an analog trigger
on with haptic feedback according to
oculus the plan is for the controllers
to make your virtual hands feel like
your real hand the rift will run
natively on Windows 10 through a
partnership with Microsoft and will let
you stream xbox one games into the rift
so you're wearing a screen that's
simulating another screen which is
streaming yet another screen it's weird
there's also going to be a steam esque
platform called home but collect your
oculus games and will work while you're
wearing the headset so you can chat with
friends as well as browse and purchase
games through the platform at your
virtual reality leisure Ratchet and
Clank fans will be happy to hear that
the upcoming game is coming packed with
a meaty resolution and a decent run time
Sony have confirmed that the game will
run at 1080p and 30 frames per second
it's also been given a release window in
the spring of next year alongside the
release of the Ratchet and Clank movie
based upon the series it's been
confirmed that the game will only run
you 40 bucks as opposed to 60 and there
should be 10 to 12 hours of gameplay to
keep you occupied not including trophy
chasing so far ratchet and clank is
promising improved visuals new planets
bosses weapons and
updated control scheme if you're a big
fan of developer insomniac games you'd
probably also be glad to hear about
their upcoming third person adventure
game edge of nowhere which has been
announced as a VR exclusive at you out
next year the game have been built from
the ground up with VR in mind so this
should be one to keep an eye on despite
the slightly odd choice of combining VR
with a third-person perspective finally
today it's been confirmed street fighter
5 and any future iterations of street
fighter 5 will not make their way to the
Xbox one although the latest entry in
the fighting series was unveiled as a
PlayStation console exclusive Capcom has
a history of iterating it's street
fighter games over time it appears that
won't be the case this time around
speculation that something like super
street fighter 5 may appear on xbox one
was shot down by a representative from
Capcom who insisted the company has a
firm partnership with Sony so don't
expect to see the game hit xbox anytime
soon at least until Street Fighter six
lands let me know down in the comments
what you think of all the oculus
announcements and if your personally
came to get into VR and why or why not
you can head to gamespot we've got you
on the division and raise up potentially
buying oh yeah I guess somebody should
those are all the things that I wanted
to tell you about today do let me know
your thoughts and viewings in the
comments down below and join me in a
super special guest tomorrow for some
top 5 goodness